you're watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the ft's
political correspondent jasmine cameron
chaleshi and the daily mail's deputy
political editor john stevens they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the mirror leads with the stabbing
of the author salman rushdie at an event
in new york state
the times reports that salman was
stabbed as many as 15 times
the male pictures the efforts to give
him first aid
the same photo appears on the front of
the sun
the express describes the incident as a
frenzied attack
it's also the main story for the
telegraph
the guardian two leads with the rushdie
attack by a masked man just as he was
about to give a speech
in other news the eye says one of the
main consequences of the drought is that
it's likely to be that crops will shrink
while the star has seen research which
found that rivers inhabited by beavers
are less prone to be affected by
droughts
and the financial times reports on the
increasing government debt and welfare
costs which will be inherited by the
next prime minister
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by jasmine
cameron chaleshi and john stevens
welcome to you both um well let's start
with this this awful attack and then the
story on salman
rushdie in new york as he was about to
to speak on stage let's start with the
the daily mail and their headline
rushdie stabbed up to
15 times jasmine
yeah i mean there are still a lot of um
unknowns about what exactly happened and
we don't exactly know the motivation of
the attacker but some details are
starting to emerge we know that
russia he was
due to be giving a talk and as part of
that talk he was supposed to be talking
about how the us was a haven for um
creative expression there are some
details emerging i think we saw the
front page of the the times that um
witnesses suggest that he was stabbed up
to um 10 to 15 times it was clearly an
incredibly violent and brutal attack and
as we know that he's now um
in hospital and they're trying to
urgently treat him but i think there
will be all sorts of questions in the
next coming days about the security of
the event and how an individual was
allowed to get so close and allowed to
bring um weaponry to an event because we
know that susan is someone who has been
on the receiving end of death threats
for for years now so i think
a lot of the details are still um
unknown but i think it will gradually
get a better understanding in the next
couple of hours and days yes and john as
jasmine says uh thoughts will turn to
security knowing salman's uh history
with the fatwa that was issued in the
80s on the the the authoring of the
satanic verses
yeah and after that fatwa was disputed
into hiding for around a decade but
clearly he felt much more comfortable
in recent years he gave an interview to
the times back in 2015 and talked about
how the last 16 years he'd use the
subway like normal he'd used things like
normal
and so as jasmine says there will be
questions about his security there's
suggestions in some of the papers that
people were able to attend this event
without having to go through bag
searches they didn't appear to have any
obvious bodyguards there and so there
will be questions about was the security
appropriate when there were these
threats to him but one of the things
that salman rushdie said himself was
that he regretted going into hiding for
10 years that he wished he hadn't done
it and he wished that he'd refused to do
that and so clearly he was making that
decision that he didn't want to live
that kind of life locked up away from
all these risks but yes he has been in
later years he he was trying to to live
his life as a normal citizen going about
his his daily business
yeah i think so and i think he is um as
john said he is someone who has given
interviews he's someone who has um
insisted that he won't be um cowed and
he's always wanted he's always been an
advocate for freedom of expression and
we've seen um several authors for
example jk rowling and political figures
such as boris johnson and the former
health secretary sergey javid come out
in
support of sir salman and arguing that
um it's an example of potentially
freedom speech being um being under
attack that those are the words of um
sergey javid on twitter earlier today
and i do think the attack will reignite
all those difficult questions about
trying to get the balance right of
freedom of um speech versus respecting
cultures and religions and i do think
we're going to see that that play out in
the next couple of days yes let's move
on to the telegraph um and there's some
more detail uh about the attack and and
the
the well the irony i suppose is that he
was speaking on the freedoms of speech
at this uh literary event john
yeah he was talking about how the us was
a refuge for
authors who were under threat and you've
got to remember the history with this
book and how much kind of
upset it caused back in the 80s
you know the papers have gone through
about how it wasn't just salman rushdie
who was the subject of these threats it
was people who were involved in
translating the book into other
languages people who were publishing it
the uh somebody translated it into
japanese was killed back in uh the early
90s i think someone who was the
publisher in norway was shot in the head
outside their home and they're also
people who were killed in massive
protests that took in different places
around the world so yeah this book has
had a massive effect
on the world and obviously a lot of
people are very concerned tonight about
salman rushdie and what's happened to
him as one of your reporters said
earlier on in the programme you know we
haven't heard many updates since uh in
the last few hours obviously when it
happened we heard reports that he was
able to walk off stage before getting
treatment but since he's been airlifted
to hospital you haven't really had many
updates on his condition and you think
if those reports are right about how he
was stabbed 15 times including in the
neck it is just a very worrying time yes
we have since then had an update from
the new york state police department and
never informed us that he is undergoing
surgery at present in the article in the
daily photograph they quote boris
johnson and he's saying that he's
appalled that sasama rushdie has been
stabbed while exercising a right we
should never cease to defend
right now my thoughts are with his loved
ones and we're all hoping he's okay uh
also in the attack henry reese the
interviewer is on stage with sassaman he
also received um a minor head injury we
read jasmine
yeah i mean we are getting the the you
know the intricacies of these details um
coming out and there's still i can
imagine it was an incredibly chaotic
scene and i can imagine there's still a
lot of confusion as to what exactly
happened but it is striking that we are
seeing individuals like boris johnson
come forward and say that actually the
the ideas of freedom of speech is i
think that we have to all defend and
yeah i think it's quite a striking
intervention and
it shows that even as john said the book
was published in the 80s and it's quite
a while ago now but actually it's still
it still resulted in huge ramifications
for those involved in translating and
for those still linked to the book and
it shows that yes it was certainly a
long time ago but actually the issues
surrounding um the text and the
controversy that's around that are still
very much alive and present today
let's have a look at the eye we'll move
on to the story of the drought and
they're detailing
a piece suggesting that the drought is
likely to shrink crops
john
yeah this is a story about obviously
we've seen the impact of the hot weather
on parks there's been those pictures and
papers for days with all the grass dried
up we've seen the impact in our gardens
and we've heard about the threat of
things like hose pipe bands but now this
is talking about how this is creating
real problems for farmers it's talking
about particular crops potatoes carrots
and onions and how the lack of water
means that we're going to get
lower yields also the individual
vegetables are going to be smaller this
year and in that eye article it quotes
the nfu and they're calling on
supermarkets to relax some of their
rules and product specifications so
you're more likely to get kind of
slightly smaller onions or potatoes on
the shelves or wonky veggies and they're
talking about if we don't do this
they're going to be even more problems
with price and we know with all the
problems going on in ukraine and how
that's impacted crops and oil production
and also with petrol prices going up and
how that's already led to shut prices
going up and up and up this is getting
the yet more pressure on shoppers
and jasmine tell us that by the the star
how beavers might help with the drought
so i mean
a slightly light-hearted take on a very
serious issue but i think it's an
example of how
ecosystems are so sensitive and we have
no idea really how the changing climate
and changing weather patterns will
impact um
animals in local areas but the star is
indicating that one potential um benefit
is that actually i think in i think
lakes and rivers where there are lots of
beavers they tend to be they're less
likely to dry out or something like that
but i think for all the
light-heartedness i think it's
interesting that we've actually seen a
change in tone when it comes to
reporting of the weather patterns lately
normally when it's when we've got a
couple of hot days in the uk you see
pictures of packed beaches and you know
tabloids giving us all those puns
whereas i think now there's a real shift
that this isn't just a couple of hot
days we seem to be having a continued
pattern of you know not having enough
rain having whether that's
hot enough to damage infrastructure to
damage
health to start impacting our reservoirs
and i do think that there is a growing
sense of urgency among environmental
campaigners and also among political
leaders um but actually we do need to be
looking at what our water companies are
doing what are the long-term plans in
place to deal with some of these
changing weather patterns that we're
seeing
indeed jasmine and john thank you very
much for the moment do stay with us much
more coming up after the break don't go
anywhere
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me jasmine cameron
chaleshi and john stevens welcome back
to both of you let's take a look at the
ft weekend uh and this article about um
well what will be in the entry for the
incoming conservative prime minister
debt payment and welfare bill set to
store
to stall to saul put my teeth back in uh
john take us into this story
yes so this is some yet more worrying uh
figures about the economy and the ft has
done an analysis looking at how much the
cost of borrowing for the government is
going to go up in the next couple of
years because of the rise in interest
rates and the rise in inflation and it
talks about how it was about 500 billion
pounds worth of government debt which is
linked to the consumer price index and
because obviously inflation
is at a 30-year high that is going up
and it's talking about how i think the
cost of borrowing is going to go up for
the government around 50 billion pounds
to 95 billion pounds next year and it
also talks about how a lot of benefits
obviously link to inflation and the
government's going to end up spending a
lot more on that and it just means that
it's even more of a headache for whoever
takes over the running of the country
and obviously during the campaign we've
heard lots of different promises from
liz trust and rishi soon i can liz
truster said a lot of them you know she
said there's head room that she does
have an ability to do a lot of her tax
cuts without any extra borrowing whereas
this brings that into question
and suggests some of those forecasts on
the economy that were drawn up by the
obr at the time of the last budget now
look rather out of date
yes they quote professor charlie bean a
former obr committee member said that
the pressures on the public finances
meant that the permanent tax cuts
promised by trust were irresponsible
this trust is thinking of permanent
reductions in the tax burden and it's a
pretty open question whether 30 billion
pounds of headroom is still there
jasmine
yeah so we're in this really strange
period at the moment where there's
almost a bit of a political vacuum
because we've had all these negative
headlines about the economy we know that
the economy shrank between june and
eight and between april and june of this
year we now know that energy prices are
set are predicted to rise um
above four thousand pounds by next um
april so about all these negative
headlines about the economy and it looks
like come autumn are going to be in
quite a tricky situation whereas but
when this position where the prime
minister and downing street have said
that they're not actually able to
intervene for the time for time being
we're gonna have to wait till september
and then we have liz trust and rishi
cenac giving us their ideas about how
they're gonna tackle the cost of living
crisis but there's skepticism about
whether or not they're even practical i
think they're clear on what they
ideologically believe cena wants to get
tackle inflation and he wants to reduce
borrowing whereas this trust wants to um
embark on a series of tax cuts but i
think there's that tension between what
they believe and actually what the
economy will allow come september when
the new pm has to come into office
let's finish with the time should we uh
john and this piece about the fact that
english a level is not as
popular as it once was slipping down the
rankings in favor of uh science subjects
yeah a decade ago the english literature
was the most popular a level subject but
according to these rankings it looks
like i think it's going to fall out of
the top ten
and that might sound a bit concerning
but you look at the subjects that are
doing particularly well maths is at the
top of the list you've got biology and
chemistry very high i think history's
gone down slightly but it's number six
in the table i think this is probably a
good thing if people are switching to
science and math subjects that for a
long time people have been kind of
encouraging it saying we want more
people to take them up and it appears
that people are taking on that message
and actually doing it
jasmine was smiling there do you
disagree
i'm slightly biased having done an
english degree and having absolutely
loved english
based when i said i was doing an english
degree but i do think it's important
that we have students studying maths and
all the sciences that get you into you
know some of these jobs that we really
need for example jobs in the nhs but i
also think we shouldn't underplay or
downplay the importance of the
humanities and you know this is the
country that gave us shakespeare and
these amazing works of literature we
also shouldn't forget that as well